So the answer to this question is the combination that leaves the most Warfarin
around to have a maximum affect. VKORC1 is involved in
the pharmacodynamic response. So if we have less of it around.
Then there's more Warfarin to VKORC1, so we can saturate our VKORC1
faster, with less VKROC1 around. CYP2C9 represents
the pharmacokinetic aspect of Warfarin, because it
metabolizes or breaks Warfarin down. Well if CYP2C9
is slow. Then that means we're going to end
up with more Warfarin around. And vitamin K
is downstream in the pathway, and since
vitamin K itself promotes blood clotting, which is
the opposite of what Warfarin is trying to do, if we have low to no vitamin
K, no leafy greens in this case, then we don't need as much Warfarin to
block the effects of the vitamin K
recycling to promote blood clotting. So less VKORC1,
a slow or reduced activity for CYP2C9. And low to no vitamin K supplemented in
other ways. Knowing your explanation that you
tried to write out to justify your combination.
Hopefully you recongize that the pharmacodynamic or PD pathway was with VKORC1.
The pharmacokinetic pathway was with CYP2C9.
And then a max toxicity, essentially is
maximizing the pharmacodynamic pathway and minimizing
the pharmacokinetic pathway. If we wanted an
optimum efficacy, minimum toxicity, we would have to be somewhere in the middle
that allows Warfarin to achieve its function of blocking some amount
of blood clotting. But not so much that it promotes bleeding. So
recognizing that this combination is not what we want is really one
of the first major steps to understanding what the right prescription is.